so welcome back
to the machine learning street talk
youtube channel
with my two compadres for today we've
got uh phd
mit dr keith duggar
and we've got yannick lightspeed culture
excellent how are you doing well yeah
we're doing pretty good well uh today we
wanted to
cover a couple of topics so there was a
huge exams fiasco in the uk
and all about algorithmic fairness and
and it had lots of coverage in the uk
and also our friend francois charles has
done a second appearance on the
lex friedman podcast yeah i guess we
should just
jump straight in and talk about the the
algorithm thing
so in the uk we've had the corona
pandemic
this year and it's been an absolute
nightmare and the
in of particular focus here is all of
the students taking their gcse and
a-level
exams couldn't do them of course so they
had to be predicted
and sorry what are what kind of are
those exams like the
the sats or are those global for the
entire uk
yes that's right so we we have gcses
which is around when you're 15 and 16
and then those lead to a level a levels
lead to university
okay so the exams this year
were predicted by an algorithm and
the reason they were predicted by an
algorithm was um the
the first idea was to use the teacher
predicted grades
but the teacher predicted grades were
inflated by about 40 percent
one of the regulators in the uk stepped
in
and this was on a dick tap by the
government the government were very
clear
that they didn't want to have grade
inflation and i can understand why
because great inflation is not good for
anyone
if you inflate the currency so to speak
or you add too much water to the mustard
then you end up with a signal which is
not particularly useful for any further
education institutions to select on so
clearly the the idea there was to bring
it down
now one of the things that concerned me
about this was the facts were not really
reported
no one no one really spoke about how the
algorithm worked
and the bbc for example widely reported
this as
the government had come in and
downgraded the results by 40
or so and the the real story in my
opinion is that the teachers inflated
the grades by 40
and the government had to come in and
just to standardize them back down again
um so i was really disappointed in
particular with the way the bbc
reported this but to the bbc's credit
i've listened to a couple of podcasts on
you know from
radio 4 and that seems to be a little
bit less biased than
iplayer and bbc news but generally
speaking it's been
very kind of misrepresented so
why don't we have a look at this
algorithm i'll share my screen
so the the algorithm is supposed to come
in after the teachers
or just completely circumvent the
teachers
well the idea is to completely
circumvent the teachers
okay and just to give some idea of the
accuracy of the teacher
assessed grades they are roughly 60
percent accurate
which isn't very good and this algorithm
that they replaced it with was also
about 60 percent accurate but it's not
about the accuracy
but what it is mean in that context does
it
like it predicts a number right every
single student will have
a fixed number of exams yeah for every
single exam they will have a grade
which is a number from one to ten and
the accuracy
is how the percentage to which that was
exactly correct
okay exactly correct okay yeah
so i don't think it was a distance
measure or anything like that
so a little bit of history if you can
see this so um
the secretary of state for education
instructed the head of off koal
to ensure as far as possible that the
qualification standards are maintained
and the distribution grades follow a
similar profile to that of previous
years
fine they were computed using an
algorithm devised by ofqua
and more than 4.6 million gcse so about
of gccs and about 87 percent of the
a-level grades were computed
it wasn't used for vocational
qualifications now this is the algorithm
now it's reasonably straightforward but
there are two versions of it so if the
cohort of students in that particular
class was less than 15
then they would revert back to the
center assessed grade which is basically
what the teacher said
now this part is probably the biggest
source of
unfairness in my opinion because private
schools tend to have
smaller classes which means they would
get the inflated teacher grades
but for the larger cohorts greater than
you can see it's a convex combination
between these two quantities
and it depends on this r here and r
basically means
do we have reliable um gcse and previous
predictions
if we do then it's a function of c
and the predicted um grades for gcses
last year
and the predicted grades for gcses for
the other classes before last year
so this c quantity here is the
historical grade distribution of
grades at that particular school
averaged over the last three years
first of all just from an ethical point
of view a lot of people think that it's
completely crazy that you could predict
someone's exam results
using the school's performance last year
because it implies a degree of
environmental determinism
and that is horrifying for people just
to think about
yeah of course people are often
horrified by the idea that
their performance is in any way
dependent
on something that isn't a magical
sort of inner quantity that we can't
like possibly define
whatever that is like soul or or uh
individual capability or or something
but at the end of the day like
scientifically we're
some of our parts right and those parts
are many things our
genetic infra information our epigenetic
information
the whole totality of information that's
been accumulated in our
neurons throughout throughout our life
and so of course
environment plays a role right of course
at least
it plays a role in a population sense
but the reason why people get so
frustrated with those quantities
being used for individuals is we have
this concept that
we have to treat everyone as an
individual and and allow for the
possibility that
in this variation within this
environment any particular individual
may excel they may underperform too by
the way it's not
it's not a single-edged sword that cuts
both ways
so that's where you get into these sort
of quagmires of like
my particular child sure they went to
this school that historically
underperforms but they as an individual
rose above that
and it's a shame if somebody doesn't
have that chance
so the just to be clear the grades were
predicted
basically for the entire class the same
so
yeah the formula says nothing about the
individual student it's basically just
you are you go to this school
and this school in his in history
did this good at math and then in this
year so these other quantities are all
referring just to this particular grade
and this particular
school that's correct yeah i should
finish
explaining so this will capture just the
grade distribution
for a particular school and then
the only signal that they do take in
then for this particular cohort
is the rank so the the school will say
this is the rank of students
and then they will take into account how
those ranks were distributed last year
so that basically capture buckets and
then
in rank order they would just drop the
grades into those buckets so if
if you had a class of the same size and
you had three a stars last year then
you'd get three a stars this year and
then your best students
would basically get those groups exactly
so assuming that the distribution is
roughly the same this seems to work
but this bit's interesting so if you do
have historical
predicted grades for gcses both for this
class and previous classes
then it takes away the difference so
this is assuming that
the the teachers are predicting
inaccurately but consistently and
accurately so if they
predicted that this particular class had
even better gcc's than they predicted
for the previous years
then let's give them the benefit of the
doubt we'll take the difference and
we'll add that on to the
the center grade distribution i've and
it's just something i've heard
is that for some schools it was
it was they basically got none of the
top grades is that correct
i i'm just i so i come i'm not
uk in i'm also not closely affiliated
and i just hear things through the ether
and
i recall some people were complaining
that it was
mathematically impossible for them to
get the highest possible grade so even
if they were
the top student in their class just
because their school wasn't doing well
previously it was they just didn't get
any allocations of
of top grades is that i don't know have
you heard anything of this or
well yes it's implicit in in the
algorithms if your class
um didn't get any a stars last year then
there will be none this year no matter
how good you are
yeah so it's it is some somehow
understandable that that would
in infuriate some people and
it's thinkable that you might want to do
something like a laplacian smoothing
to basically say okay we'll give each
school at least one
super duper grade or something like this
such that in the off case that someone
rises above
massively this outliers that can be
captured
i can see that it is annoying right that
you go to this and just
and you're doing so well and then this
algorithm comes and you're just
out like go right there there goes your
chance yeah
but in fact it happened sorry kate no
especially because it's only taking into
account
one year right like just just last year
maybe last year we didn't have any
any a stars but if you look over i don't
know
five or ten years maybe on average we
had
two every year or something like that
and just of course by
hasan statistics we happen to run into a
case where we didn't have any
last year it's sort of a legitimate
complaint there
well it takes the average over the last
three years
that should smooth that a little bit
it's a tough one because i want to get
into the ethics of this a little bit
because um
one of the reasons why people were so
annoyed about this was fundamentally
they resent this idea of environmental
determinism and they think
that we are a blank slate and if
anything they think the university
should
positively discriminate and allow
students in from poorer areas as a
matter of course
well i think they're just out of touch
with with modern science and i think i
think the blank slate
idea at least as far as i'm i'm aware in
scientific circles
is discredited we're not a blank slate
if you look at any personality kind of
traits or
things like that on average they have at
least 50 percent correlation with your
with your genetics right at least in the
sort of current environments in which
that data was collected which is mostly
say united states and western kind of
environments
obviously that's a variable that changes
with time so in some parts of the world
where say malnutrition
is is very prevalent that's going to
increase
the variation that environment plays in
that and so that balance can change or
for example
in some parts of the southern united
states there are even
parasites that can cause uh mental
problems if you get them as a young
child like the
the stereotype of a slack-jawed
southerner actually is in part due to
parasitic organisms that live down the
south so that's a
thing that changes with time but it's
absolutely understood that
in large parts of the western world
genetics accounts for half or more
depending on the trait that you're
looking at and the funny part is
nobody has any qualms whatsoever with
admitting this about say
eye color right is it controversial that
eye color is heritable
is it controversial that hair color is
heritable
no is it controversial that height that
skin color etc if you go to any kind of
disease prevalence your susceptibility
to heart disease
all of these things doctors ask you do
you have a family history of xyz
why because scientifically we know it
matters and nobody has a problem with it
if it's like a
a base physical trait well what is the
brain
it's an organ right it's a bio it's a
bio machine
it's obviously all the other organs in
our body
going to inherit traits based on its its
genetic code
and therefore the things which your
brain does
personality computation understanding
intelligence
whatever have to have some heritability
it's just it would be preposterous to
believe that it
that it doesn't frankly yeah on the
so on the very on the other side i think
you can make an argument that systems
like this
are self-replicating in a way so if you
take it to the very extreme and say
okay we have a pandemic now forever
and all we're going to do is simply use
the same algorithm
over and over again the schools that
didn't get any good students this year
they will never
get any and that's also not their
you know his society is always changing
and these poor areas might be
because traditionally you know the good
schools will attract the
rich people living around them they'll
pay more taxes and that'll again
uplift the kind of quality of the school
and so on and
this might have been in change in flux
during this time
so yeah i'm i would i and
they probably have considered this like
doing
the way i said is you do some kind of
laplacian smoothing where you just say
okay every school gets one
like countries do when they have
differently sized states or member
members where they say okay by default
everyone gets two representatives and
then
on top is the population something
like this where you just account for for
that initial change to happen and
maybe they've considered it i don't know
it's so hard so imagine someone comes to
you
and is okay there is no like it's ruled
out that we're going to do these exams
it's just not possible you can debate
that whether it was possible or not
during this pandemic but
let's say someone comes and says it's
not possible
but we need grades what are you going to
do it's so hard and
some people i feel are you know voice
their complaints but also
i don't want to be in that situation
it's terrible
yeah you raise an interesting point
because what's really important i think
as a mitigating factor here is that
they've only done it once
because you can say just as you did that
if they do this again and again
then similar to training a language
model on data from the 1950s
you're kind of freezing things in time
and you're stopping
people from being able to evolve
socially and
and so on from a from an ethical point
of view
i i worry that it undermines trust in in
algorithms because we don't really have
much trust in algorithms at the moment
that the government used them to see
where we should spend our money and
whether people are falling into
homelessness and who's cheating the
benefit system and policing and
of course algorithms are used on social
media like facebook and netflix
and they work incredibly well uh it's
not just learning
your recommendations from your behavior
it's looking you know
at patterns and it's looking at you in
context to people like you and they work
really well
and i think it undermines trust in
algorithms
i think people already have a really bad
conception of algorithms because of
cambridge analytica
and this was one of the first times
where loads of students actually came
out to protest an algorithm
which seems crazy because there was
still grade inflation
and everyone did pretty well so is it
why are students coming out and
protesting when they didn't even have to
take any exams and the grades still
inflated over last year
well we have to unpack some things there
because there's a couple
points you raised as far as the mistrust
and algorithms
look at the end of the day the
algorithms were just created by people
and so to some extent we should mistrust
algorithms as much as we mistrust people
and
and clearly people don't really trust
people we've been having
issues with fairness and grading and
every other circumstance for a long time
you look at that number 15
what's so special about 15 15 some kind
of magic number like gee
if if only we had 16 data points then
it's reliable
it's so people make these
i don't know if i can say poor decisions
but arbitrary
questionable decisions all the time
either writing code
not in this particular case but say in
other algorithmic situations they're
writing code
of such a complexity that only small
portions of the human
species really can write them correctly
in the first place
so we should have a healthy mistrust of
algorithms and i think that's why
transparency like this making the
algorithms publicly being able to
discuss them
being able to have candid conversations
about what kinds of correlations
are we allowed to use and what kinds are
we not allowed to use
is probably like really the path that we
have to start taking steps down
to wrangle this but hey look at the end
of the day
if people mistrust algorithms just ask
them okay
so would you rather just have one person
making the decision
is that i don't think they're going to
be happy with either that so
i don't that's one of the key things is
that we're just swapping one problem for
another problem
and in many ways an algorithm is better
because it's completely transparent
and at least it's repeatable yeah it's
repeatable and i can see some benefits
about this they clearly designed it
carefully because they wanted to
explicitly avoid racial bias and
the teachers arguably are far more
biased than the algorithm were so
now that the only real bias is is the
the environmentally determined bias but
it does raise
issues about ai ethics in general
because the government wants to be data
driven everyone wants to be more data
driven
and ethics in general is quite an
interesting thing right
i'm involved in quite a lot of the ai
ethics and data ethics discussions
at my work and clearly one of our
one of our rules that you see all over
the place is that you shouldn't be
making consequential decisions about
people's future
because you need to respect the the
dignity of folks
and quite often the rule goes something
like this if there's an anthropocentric
objective then you know you should try
and
avoid it if at all possible especially
if it's consequential
but this is an example where you're
between a rock and a hard place
and you quite simply need to do it
there's no other alternative in fact i
think it's better than the alternative
if you had to argue
it does bring the whole discussion of ai
ethics into the fort because
as well as being transparent i think
your reasoning needs to be recorded
because our ethical
landscape changes all the time if you're
if you say i'm an ethical
company what that means is that you have
a certain set of values
and you're being consistent to those
values and
people's opinions change all the time if
there was a statue of barack obama
they they might tear it down in 50 years
time because he wasn't a vegan
so much um maybe 20 years
well exactly but there's a lot of moral
posturing and this is something i notice
with
ai ethicists online is that they talk
about it as if it
is a really absolute thing that we
should all agree on and
we should talk to social scientists to
get ideas about ai ethics and of course
most of these folks
have been educated into imbecility and
they
um come from a post-modernist viewpoint
and so on
yeah but i i really think it's a cop-out
to say let's not make any consequential
decisions with algorithms because again
what's the alternative should we flip a
coin that's what the joker
says or whoever the dude was and the
comic says it's fair
or should we just leave it up to the the
whims of a single judge
let's have or is a committee better
there's no easy answers here
like yannick brought up earlier it's
okay you can't take tests
so now what do you do i don't think an
algorithm should have 15 in it
like i agree with you that's probably a
source of huge amounts of
bias to smaller class sizes but we've
got to have
rules and what are algorithms they're
sets of rules
so i think we're going down the right
path of using algorithms but we have
to do openly we've got to do the very
hard work
of reaching consensus on what these
algorithms are allowed to do
and what they're not allowed to do in
terms of how they're actually
implemented what correlations they use
data bias fairness et cetera but we
can't just say
we're not going to make any cons
consequential decisions with them
i know but i think it changes depending
on the circumstances
it depends how risk-averse the
particular company is and
a moral framework is a continuum so for
example if you were an environmentalist
you would think that oil companies
should stop trading tomorrow and they
should just pack up their bags and stop
fighting
and millions of people should die yeah
yeah and
if you might believe that the profit
motive is completely
morally abhorrent as well and actually
this brings me on to something quite
interesting so i was looking at this
thing yesterday microsoft had brought
out this tool called fair learn
and this is a way of um understanding
various different
biases in in ai models and so on and the
first example on here is loading in a
data set and
um plotting the difference between the
earnings of men and women
and clearly this is a politically
charged thing right because if you were
on the on the right you would argue that
uh women have a choice right they if
they decide to
start a family then they are
economically disadvantaging themselves
and people on the left would have a
completely different opinion and say
that we should
we should counteract that disadvantage
and and we should pay men and women
equally
but it does rather lead to a discussion
of the political slant in the way that
we are discussing ai ethics
and fairness yeah
i guess more and more you can frame
almost any
almost anything that where an algorithm
touches society
and you can ethically analyze pretty
much
anything and maybe if you go a bit
further you can problematize pretty much
anything though
this great thing it really hits close to
to home like if you think back of you as
a student regardless of whether you
thought it was
an accurate assessment of your abilities
you would have
hated this thing especially if you're
doing fairly well and you
thought maybe if i give it my all i can
do something though probably not right
probably not but
you you want to chance yeah exactly i
think that's
that's what bugs people and here we can
look at it in the terms of
in the terms of kind of this
so i think a prevalent question in these
frameworks is always
let's look at who is harmed by this and
who is benefited by an algorithm like
this
and to me if i look at it like this it's
not entirely
clear because who is actually who does
it benefit small
class sizes okay maybe because then the
grade is inflated
by the teachers if it's below 15 but
who is harmed let's so if you're
harmed if yeah you are this really
stellar
outlier in a school that does not have
stellar outliers
right then okay but that's
it is unfair but it is excessively rare
you're also harmed if you're in a small
class and there happens to be this one
other person that just is better because
it's rank order
so you're not given the chance to
achieve a good score in this test
because
this other person is just that much
better and you're in the small class
and therefore your rank order matters
really much but the small classes are
already inflated
it's really oh like the actual big harm
seems to be
if if you were just statistically
outlier is good that year but your
school isn't
for the rest of people probably
it was okay-ish accurate and
i agree with with you tim it's easy to
get
to loudly voice your opinion to
something like this
because you you could hardly find anyone
who says yeah okay that
that's a good thing it's it's but if to
those who voice opinion
the question is just how would you do it
better like i
i said okay you could do this laplacian
smoothing to account for these
stellar outliers in each school which
would harm
people that are on the margins because
then all the other schools that would
actually be good
will get one place less and there would
be always the student that is at the cut
off that is now
dropped because of this you know what
the other
the other thing that really concerns me
about the way in which
excuse me a lot of the public looks at
this is they're forgetting about very
real
correlations and the importance of
correlations it's like i've had so many
discussions with
a.i ethicists where at the end of the
day it seems to me
bias is really correlations we we don't
like
like that's essentially what it comes
down to like that example you just
brought up from microsoft
okay obviously if there's a pay gap
based on gender maybe we need to have
some discussions about
who should be bearing the burden of
child bearing should it solely be women
should it be society should it be
employers et cetera there's some
legitimate conversation there
on the other hand what if they had shown
that exact same
website except instead of pay gap they
put
prevalence of breast cancer is anyone
surprised by the fact that 95 percent of
breast cancer cases would be women
is that a correlation that we want to
ignore
i don't think so because that's going to
impact negatively
the medical care of women if we just try
to make our algorithms completely ignore
gender for all purposes and so
we almost need to have a community
driven a crowd source
database of correlations and purposes
and whether or not that's okay to use it
for that purpose
that's the can of worms we're opening is
yes you can use
the gender factor for medical care
but not for job selection can you can't
you
maybe you can depending on the
jurisdiction you're in use it for
deciding who wins custody
in the case of a divorce how about that
there's a bunch of gray areas right
but we we can't if we make our
algorithms so
dumb that they can't discover very
real correlations we run the risk of of
destroying tremendous
value that those algorithms can bring
yeah and i think in the terms of this
these great distributions there are some
quite nasty correlations right as tim
said the small classes they tend to be
the rich people and correct so you're
like by employing that algorithm
one year more you're basically giving an
already predetermined advantage
to those people now that might be
completely justified because they might
be
actually better but still people feel
that
and then on the other hand who who
is who gets the lower grade
distributions it's going to be the
i don't know again about the uk but it
would be the inner city
maybe foreigner population immigrant
population that is less educated
would be assigned the lower grades and
that just rubs people
in the wrong way it and it does so
almost regardless of the fact
that if you are really if you're if you
play tough love you'd have to say look
very probably that is going to be the
great distribution again this year
right in this school in both cases if
you
are honest it's that but it just people
find it and i can understand that people
say look this is just
upholding these kind of things that we
don't really want yeah yeah
it comes back to the dichotomy between
equality of opportunity and equality of
outcome as well because
some of these fairness things are
basically saying that we should
we shouldn't take reality as it is
because reality is wrong
we should move towards the kind of
reality that that we want to live in
and that's why this is always quite a
politically charged conversation
on this for example if you give a bunch
of
inflated grades to students you are it's
like inflating the currency
it's worth less and this year it didn't
seem to be the case so there's been
massive
over oversubscribed courses at
universities and some of the students
have been deferred to next year
and that means that now the folks next
year have to do even better than they
did before
because they are competing for folks
that were deferred
to next year this time around and i also
want to bring in
to the conversation why do we have
university at all is it something which
is completely outdated
is it part of our civic life you know is
is it something which is a great moral
achievement for us
in the uk we had this political target
set recently that 50
of folks should be educated to
university level
almost all parents aspire to have their
kids to be educated at university level
and now the education secretary has
finally said well we're training for
jobs that don't even exist
that's right people doing
apprenticeships are earning more money
basically the 13 least prestigious
universities are about to go out of
business
and university education isn't for
everyone but is that just snobbishness
no not look so i'm most familiar with
the united states right where
where i am obviously and so what
the way we do it here is people are
guaranteed education for 12 years
well up to 12th grade which is 18 and
maybe they had
some preschool or whatnot and my kind of
take on this is
if we can't if here we're not teaching
people
enough to be successful in life after 12
years of education okay
we're doing something wrong for example
and again i don't live in germany but my
understanding there
for example is that at the age of 16
a lot of folks go into kind of
vocational paths where they do
apprenticeships essentially like
old-school apprenticeships and learn
successful trades and that people take
tests and only a small percentage of
people
end up going to university at the
state's expense right and i just think
that
i think what's happened is we've
forgotten that life is not
monolithic there is no one way in which
life live what life is this vast complex
network of
niches everywhere and people can fill so
many different roles in life
and yet we've created this
one-size-fits-all
education system that tries to funnel
everyone down
a single path and that just doesn't seem
to reflect the reality of
of life and work and we should instead
what we should be focusing on
is for each individual what are they
passionate about
what do they want to do what are they
good at doing
and what are the overlaps of those
things and and what areas in life
would you be really happy and and very
productive in and contributing to
society and what path
how can i help you get from where you
are today to that point
and i think we'd have a huge variety and
it's not 50
of people going to study psychology like
here in the us
yeah i think in germany it's also been a
bit inflated in the last few years but
you're essentially right in the
in the kind of path that people can
choose in switzerland it's still a bit
less than in germany people going to
university and as you say
people are mostly either taking up
vocational
training manual or jobs like this at 16
or they go into
specialized schools at 16 like real
trade schools and there's nothing wrong
with those
jobs no no there's no trees fantastic
but we have this
this weird thing where it's somehow bad
to be a cnc operator
it's it's bad to be a farmer it's bad to
be an electrician a plumber a painter
why are
these are noble pursuits you know i
completely agree
oh sorry yeah um in fact
so in switzerland i just know the system
here right there is always a path
to higher education and that's what i
like about it is that
for the people who go into trades or go
into these kind of very specialized
schools there is paths that lead back to
higher education in case they want to
add on in case they want to do more
academic things so a lot of
people come from very different paths to
higher education that's pretty cool it's
still i think
20 to 30 percent of people still end up
at university at some point but
it's not they come they split up and
they learn their trades and so on and
so that means a lot of people in
university actually have business
experience already
working experience so it's pretty pretty
cool but
in that case it is it's good it's nice
to say
everyone their thing and so on but then
what do we do in school
there's this great this is one number
right and
you're ranked like literally in this
algorithm you're ranked
by this number and everyone's ranked by
that number and that number
even if you go into a trade school that
number
predicts how happy the trade school is
to see you and that's
it's partially the fault of our society
by not differentiating the students
enough but
in the other hand it's it's the fault of
biology because there's this thing
called intelligence and the more you
have of it the better you'll do in
whatever right it keeps getting in the
way doesn't it you can have different
interests and and what not but
ultimately it's you can
so i i think we could definitely do a
better job of differentiating students
splitting them up earlier especially in
the us 12 years
and but also this is reflected in these
tests because
everyone takes the test and then
everyone gets one number
and that determines and the the
universities can put
at the top as the kind of if you're this
good or better
you can go to university right it's
right
yeah it does raise the question though
because it's never been easier to get to
university i think it's fair to say now
in the uk if you want to go to
university you can
as an example i i don't have any
a-levels at all i was a complete idiot
at school and i started a software
company in my 20s and i think when i was
about 24
i just showed up at a local university
and said look actually
i'd quite like go to university after
all can i come in and they said yeah you
seem like a fairly intellectually
mature kind of guy we'll let you come in
you can skip the first year i got a
first class degree
and i'm a big believer that if you work
hard first of all i don't think
university is that big of a signal
anymore google have just said that they
are now going to
provide a vocational course so you can
do a six month certificate to work at
google
and i'm not sure that's a good thing
because it's basically if you
indoctrinate yourself taking our course
then you can come and work at google
microsoft do similar certificates by the
way microsoft certifications but
ironically if you had one
they probably wouldn't employ you but
but university though it's more than
it's more than than economic
utilitarianism
i think there's an argument that you go
there and you're you are exposed to
ideas that are different to yours
although admittedly most of the ideas
are
quite leftist ideas these days but it's
a lot of people think of it as their
formative years
i would agree with that to a certain
extent but you could also make the
argument that
maybe if you just move to another city
and just join some interest clubs and so
on
uh take yannick's youtube channel for
example it's never been easier
for someone to go online learn about
machine learning
you can see world-class lectures on
youtube you can
start coding on github you can if you're
an industrious hardworking person
you have a wealth of opportunity and you
don't really need to go to university do
you
well see so about that it's occurred to
me that
the big difference there is that in
universities you're or before
covid you were forced to be together
that's how you ran into people that had
other ideas so it's like the
the proverbial water cooler at work
right everybody has to go there to get
some drink
back in the old days now everybody
probably has bottled water at their desk
but whatever
everybody has to go somewhere to uh my
town is the garbage dump
everybody goes there a lot of people
drop off their own garbage so you run
into people there but
the point is if you get people that have
to go somewhere physically
then they have this chance of
interacting with others the weird thing
about
the age the internet age is that rather
than being this massive water cooler
it's actually more like this massive
hallway
with a bunch of highly specific doors
to little dungeons that people go and
they walk into and they never come out
again
you become very crystallized in the way
that you think because
you can just be on the youtube channels
that you and enjoy and agree with and
you can follow people that you agree
with and there's no mechanism really
that in fact the algorithms are even
tuned now
to make it so that you rarely get
exposed to anything that you're not
going to be
agreeing with and highly engaged with so
i almost i'm waiting for
some technology to emerge in cyberspace
that finds a way of forcing people that
don't agree with each other to spend
time together
i don't know how that's going to happen
though
cool well yeah it's it's a really
interesting discussion
i suppose my career is built on machine
learning and i see this as an
existential threat
it's a little bit like the freedom of
speech debate now you can't offend
anyone and if you're saying anything of
any importance to a large group of
people you're going to offend someone
and it's a similar argument here it's
the argument of the edge case
well you might discriminate against one
person unfairly therefore you can't do
this thing and
statistics is all about the group it's
not about the individual it's
it's a utilitarian thing that works most
of the time and
i'm a little bit resistant to arguments
of the edge case if that makes sense
yeah it's it's the edge case on one case
and on the other case it's really i
think what people have a problem with is
that
it perpetuates the status quo right yeah
and i already fear we learn we learn to
drive here at
what 18 and if you're below 21 or 23 or
so your car insurance costs more
and you can already be furious at that
just
and if you're male it probably costs
right just because i'm yeah i drive well
if you just were to look at me right if
you just look at me drive i drive
i haven't had an accident and whatnot
but it doesn't matter i'm
yeah sorry it's just a trade-off just on
that though
as a young male you are brimming with
testosterone and you drive like a
complete idiot
you're more aggressive i don't think any
young male is complaining to their local
member of parliament saying they're
paying too much of my car insurance
well here's something interesting in the
u.s some insurance companies have
started to allow you to connect a
a device to your vehicle that that
tracks your driving
like how suddenly you're stopping the
speeds that you're going etc
and you it can collect individual data
on you as an individual
and as a result of that you can get
lower rates but is this interesting
you're pointing out something very
fundamental here which is yeah machine
learning statistics etc
it's all about learning from large
sample sizes
i.e groups essentially and yet at least
what we strive for say in the united
states and lots of the western world is
for everyone to be treated as an
individual
so it's like when janet brought up
earlier look uh just let's just say we
can't do these tests for whatever reason
i almost was thinking to myself how
about we just demand that we find a way
to do these tests like whether they're
done virtually or whatever let's
find let's build some solution to where
we can assess
the individuals as individuals i think
we really have to strive
you know for that somehow yeah i think
that's absolutely right so
you could call it um more of a
personalized approach to
pattern recognition health companies are
doing a similar thing so in health
insurance there are
applications that you can download and
they ask you a series of questions and
you can
do some gamification in there and you
can say that i'm doing this amount of
exercise and
it all of this essentially allows you to
demonstrate that you are not the typical
person in your demographic you are
someone who takes personal
responsibility for your well-being
and you are doing all of these things
and i completely agree with
that's in some sense that's more fair
yeah and at that point it just becomes a
question of money
basically i would have welcomed you know
the uk to say
let's do the tests like there is because
just that's let's say the fairest to the
individual but again
you'd run into problems what do you do
online tests okay some people
they don't have a quiet room at home
like literally this is
this this this whole covet thing is
probably
drives the biggest divide between rich
and poor
because you're if you're in a fairly
wealthy family
you have a room at home all the kids
they have their own computers they have
their quiet
rooms and so on and in other families
literally like the computer is in the
living room
and it's loud all the time
someone watches tv in the background
nowhere to do homework or
attend your classes and it's going to be
like
even if you say let's find a way to do
these tests i i think
not only would it probably cost enormous
amounts of money to do them
anyway it would cost even more to do it
to do them in a way that doesn't
discriminate further that the things
that are already
kind of in imbalance among the students
it's like it's almost
unsolvable problem at that point well so
i want to
challenge that a bit so i agree there's
cost but i'm not and and i don't have
any data to back this up i think we're
speculating at this point but
i'm not convinced that it's a cost
that's that outweighs the value we would
get
as a society if we really started to
tackle
some of those opportunity issues like
for example there was just a court
decision in california
that now california universities can't
use sats and
acts this year for admission because
folks with physical challenges physical
disabilities have been having a lot more
difficulty getting access
to those tests during uh covet right and
i've long
felt that one of the best things we
could do in the united states to help
our education
system is make it to where parents if
they choose just by they can choose to
drop off their children
at seven a.m in the morning and pick
them up at five or six pm in the
afternoon at school
and for that whole time they're they get
breakfast they're taken
watched over in the morning after school
they have activities they can do
i had after school care at my at my
little school when i was a child that my
mother didn't have to pay for and it
really enabled her as a single mom
to be able to work and not have to worry
about me until till five o'clock and i
think that would maybe cost us 50
percent more
of what we're spending in education
right now and yet i think the payback
would be
multiple times that so i think some of
these issues we should really do the
hard work
of looking into it and investigating it
and maybe doing some proofs of concept
like what if we make
testing areas available that not only
service testing areas but service study
areas
for kids as well and yeah it provides
computers
for kids that don't have computers and
there's tutors nearby
maybe if we build that type of
infrastructure we'll get far more value
out of it than just solely the
being able to conduct tests for
individuals fairly
yeah that makes sense yeah i completely
agree with that
i think that's very fair well i'd
we'd be talking about this for nearly an
hour we should move on to francois
chalet which is the second part of the
street talk conversation today i i took
some notes on chile's interview with
with
lex and it was a great interview and
yannick and i have probably put out
about eight what
eight hours worth of content on chalet
in the last few months
it's absolutely insane and we so you're
fan boys
we are fanboys but it seems like not
much of the community
is uh so you're forward thinking
families
or fanboys of a forward thinker
you're ahead of your time so that my
videos get they get significantly less
views
on this on that particular paper but who
knows why
maybe the thumbnails were also not that
great or so well because intelligence is
very offensive
we've been discussing that for the past
hour it just gets in the way of
everything it's
it's not good so i think it's that's
what's driving folks away
indeed i must admit it was quite a
difficult paper to
read just in terms of length it was a
huge paper it took me a couple of
weekends to read it
and i got the distinct impression that
lex didn't read it actually which
irritated me a tiny bit because he asked
at one point what is a prior and what
his experience and i'm fairly sure
alexa's got a phd in machine learning
from mit i'd expect him to know what
that was but
just in summary hey in fairness okay in
fairness i
often ask dumb questions because i
really want to
to get the other person's input on that
and sometimes
maybe i knew 90 of what they said but
that 10 percent can be a little gem that
i learned so maybe
let's give them the benefit yeah we're
giving the benefit of the doubt he was
probably
teasing it out but charlay's main ideas
around intelligence is that it's a
process and
the output is a skill so if you can
think of a rail
road builder would be a form of
intelligence and the rail road itself
would be
a skill and his fundamental idea is that
it's all about an information conversion
ratio so going from
information about something to a skill
program and
the information in a kind of area or a
space of potential
tasks is intelligence to a certain
extent so
put more formally it's the the
efficiency at which you can
transform information into skill
programs and when you look at the
formalism in his
paper he formalizes intelligence within
a space of possible things you can do
as a function of generalization
difficulty normalized by priors times
experience
and priors are for example in a cnn the
prior is the local connectivity and the
convolution
and experience is just how much training
data or how many things that you've seen
so chalet's conception essentially is
that you can
buy skill with unlimited priors and
experience and that's what's happening
in the deep learning world at the moment
and true intelligence is being able to
broadly generalize
from a few examples of something so i
have not
i've not watched the interview but
i'm pretty sure they've touched on gpt
3.
have they have i mean to be honest so i
took notes on the interview and almost
all of it is rehashing stuff that we've
done to death and there's no point going
over it again
so i i feel like i have to look i i
watch the interview
and i have a lot of agreement with with
the
general ideas and and directions that
he's trying to go
the point he's trying to make but i want
to bring up some things so last year do
you know who patrick winston is
phd student of marvin minsky so one of
the one of the very early ai
fathers or sons and fathers here at
least and he was a professor
at mit and i happened to take ai
like an ai course from him and he
started off the course by making what i
thought was a really
important point about how we perceive
intelligence so he talked about
one of the very early artificial
intelligence problems was symbolic
integration
okay and he said that used to be one of
the case studies in my course we would
go into great detail about
how symbolics was written how it does
integration et cetera and
really dive through the algorithms in
detail and he said i got to the end of
that section and one of my students and
raised his hand said
that's not intelligent and so i have
some
why not and he says well it just
integrates the same way i do
it so essentially he's saying like what
the way humans integrate equations
isn't intelligence either and so i worry
that
if you go down this path it's almost
like a no true scotsman sort of thing
where we start to say well look
whatever machines are doing they're not
intelligent but people are and then if
we start to
mathematically define that further and
further it's been 25 years or something
we'll find out that humans aren't
intelligent either and it actually we
don't know of anything that is
intelligent and so lost the ability to
have
useful conversations about intelligence
that's my
worry about this path it's funny you say
that charlay
references that in his paper it's called
the mccorduck effect which is
every time there's a big breakthrough in
ai there's a chorus of people that say
oh that's not really ai you're right to
go a bit further
but you have to admit that there is
something
where you can't describe it but you say
you
see something let's say you have no like
c3po do something and you don't know if
it's the animated one or the one with a
person inside it right so so you don't
know whether that's an a
and you see that thing do something and
there is something where you can say wow
that was smart
like that was intelligent as you
have an innate sense of what it means to
be
intelligent to be smart and well i hear
you about what worries me
is that look we have a history of humans
innate senses ending up being quite
flawed
sort of outlooks on the world right now
what worries me is that as we start to
formalize because at some point we do
need to formalize these concepts right
as we start to formalize those innate
senses
and let's say i don't know maybe we end
up deciding that true intelligence is
how quickly you can process
second order logic or something like
that and then we decide well
now that we've defined that and we built
a machine that can do that really well
that's no longer intelligence
that's what kind of worries me it's
always going to be a frontier
that we'll never reach it's sort of like
with chess okay is alpha zero
intelligent it it obliterates human
beings
is it intelligent well in one sense it's
able to adapt to new positions
on the chessboard that it's never seen
before but on the other hand if you took
alpha zero and had it play
fisher random chest would it do so well
i don't know and therefore
since it didn't do well it's no longer
intelligent
or what about if if alpha zero plays
enough games and at some point it's
literally just
solved the p space complete problem and
therefore always mates exactly the same
move because it knows precisely the
correct move
does it suddenly go from being
intelligent to not intelligent
because now it's just a deterministic
solution
yeah that's quite an interesting point
that on alphago
it's been trained on infinite amounts of
training data so
even with its limited generality it does
have some general attitude but it's been
self-playing millions and millions of
times
you raise something interesting though
which is we have an innate sense of
when someone is intelligent but our
intuitions can be wrong because if it's
a human
gary kasparov clearly learned how to
play chess so that's quite an
interesting signal but
of an ai and our intuition breaks and we
can easily be fooled into thinking
something is intelligent
well i wouldn't so no offense to gary
kasparov but i would not
consider that intelligent because and
because i know if you have
let's say the the mental precondition
to do that this sort of stuff well and
you practice a lot
then you'll you're gonna get there it's
like athletics
if you are if your body is just there is
a mix of your body being built for this
and you practicing a lot and that's you
know what makes a world-class
athlete and they're in a isn't there an
efficiency thing there though
so gary kasparov developed those skills
more efficiently
than another person would have and it
seems that by chalet's definition that's
what makes him
that's intelligent yes yeah although i
think his contrast with efficiency is
that
all of the ais at the moment are
incredibly sample and efficient
uh we'll get on to self-driving cars in
a minute but they needed to be
trained on the equivalent of hundreds
and thousands of hours of driving
whereas humans can learn to drive in
in a couple of weeks so i think with
gary kasparov it wasn't so much that he
could learn
it quickly it was more that he learned
it to a high
level and because chile talks about the
g factor
and there are so many correlates in
cognitive ability so
it's almost like an implication that if
you can learn chess
to a high standard then it implies that
you're very good at other cognitive
tasks
which wouldn't be the case with alpha
zero certainly not
no not at all but just to rewind a tiny
bit so
some of the topics that charlay spoke
about was gpt3
he spoke about some conceptions of deep
learning
logical approaches versus vector-based
approaches he spoke about the meaning of
life at the end
he spoke about hutter's conception of
intelligence as being a form of
compression
which is an old idea and something that
he thinks is flawed he spoke about the
turing test
he spoke about neural link this new
thing with elon musk
why don't we start with neural link and
then we'll go on to gbt3 which is quite
interesting on neural link he says that
he's very skeptical about it because
it's being pitched as the next big thing
he thinks that we already take in way
more information than we can process
and our intelligence is externalized via
things like wikipedia and even culture
as a form of externalized
intelligence he thinks that we already
have access to all the information
the bottleneck is our brain it's really
slow and conscious thought takes several
seconds so it wouldn't really make any
difference if we had a neural link
are you like i i i highly disagree with
that because
if i don't know a particular fact
that i need to know i need to go
to my laptop or my phone type it in get
up the web page
read it in and then i have that
information available
if there was something if nearly i don't
have no clue what it does i think now
they just want to battle
things like seizures with it like
epilepsy
you just counter those signals in the
brain blindness
blind things like damages but if
the end goal i think that they have and
that's what elon
musk says in multiple interviews is that
you know your bandwidth
right now it's two thumbs and and with
that i agree it's
yes our brain might be slower than a
computer in terms of
number crunching or signal sending and
whatnot
but in terms of getting information from
the outside
into the brain it's there can be a lot
of speed up
well that's interesting so you're making
the point that for high velocity query
type information so if i want to know
what the weather is in australia i don't
even need to get out of my bed i can
just find out i can know immediately
i've already got a google home in my
bedroom so i guess i could just ask the
google home
but charlay's point is that with reading
at the moment
if you increase the reading speed let's
say to 500 words a minute you understand
less of it
so the bottleneck seems to be the brain
processing speed
all i can say is sorry we better be very
careful with this because
as much as my mind wanders i just see
myself getting hooked up to
neural link and suddenly i just melt
down because
i asked a question got the answer that
led me to another question just infinite
loop like out of existence so whatever
he does
put in some bandwidth limiters there
please because
i wonder whether it would cause some
dangerous behaviors because one of the
reasons for the obesity epidemic is
the food environment it's never been
easier to access hyperpalatable food and
maybe people will become addicted to
problem gambling online or something
because they can do it through their
neural link while they're sleeping way
easier you just stimulate whatever gives
you dopamine
there's these right there's these
experiments with rats where they can
choose between
between a dopamine or serotonin
dosage in their brain like an electrode
and food and they they just hit that
thing until they're dead
i seem to recall some science fiction
novel about this where essentially the
culture went down this path
and they ended up being essentially just
these brains and jars
that where everything was automated and
they communicating with each other
through
their version of neural link or whatever
at some point another civilization shows
up at their planet
it's like oh wow look at all these
available resources here with
it's just these jars and brains they
start taking over the place and and
the brains are just pontificating about
how this is morally wrong
and shouldn't be happening and they
can't do anything to stop it because
they no longer really have
any type of one of the issues i always
have with the comparisons of humans
to artificial intelligence is it's not
clear to me that we're judging
apples for apples okay the human brain
by some measures
is all inefficient and slow and whatever
but not if you start to look at it in
terms of
its power consumption in terms of the
fact that it's a
self-replicating or at least a species
of self-replicating organisms
that can function well in this
environment on earth and resource like
there's a lot of constraints
that are ignored like whenever somebody
brings up the what if i invent
an ai that makes paper clips and it just
decides
in order to do that it has to strip mine
the earth and start spreading through
the solar system to make more and more
paperclips because it's just better
they've always
allied the energy requirements basic
physics
gravity could this happen et cetera so
there's a lot of constraints that get
ignored
in these sort of scenarios i think yeah
and you just jog my memory a little bit
just there keith because because you you
talked about
minsky's last student i think uh that
you met
patrick winston yeah patrick yeah and of
course minsky's conception of
intelligence was about reasoning over
knowledge
uh using cultural propositions and i
think more recently
ai has been conceived as a search
problem
more than anything else or possibly a
learning or generalization problem
although they're strongly related
and i've been interested in
open-endedness recently i know we've
spoken about this keith and
of course all all good search problems
have deception and sometimes there's a
false compass you need to do the
opposite of what you think you need to
do
in order to achieve greatness and so any
ai that we
could produce in the future i don't
think we really have a handle on what
that's going to look like
sure i wanted to come back to what you
said what and what show they said before
that if you speed up reading
you're just going to understand less and
to me that
like it's conceivable that you have
different
parts of your brain that one does
reading comprehension
like from visual input to where
you have a kind of internal
representation of the information
and that seems to be the same process i
was talking about when i want to look up
a fact it's
whenever i want there's this page of of
text and i want to get in
into my brain i think that has
little to do with how fast once it's in
you can do computations with the thing
so in that fascinating point yeah
i disagree and besides that we all
really want the
to have that thing plugged in and the
first thing we do is learn
kung fu so we can recreate the scene
from the movie
well it's quite interesting on that
point because earlier on in the lex
interview he
asserted that chomsky has this
conception of language as being a system
of thought and
chile said that he thought that language
was a bit like an operating system in
our mind
and who's to say that we need to ingest
the book
in language form maybe the newer link
could learn to
represent it in some deeper structure so
we could acquire the information more
efficiently
that's how i see yanik's point is i
actually i don't think language
is an operating system to me analogies
are what they are but i would have i
would have thought it was more like the
shell
the shell language to the operating
system
so i think what was interesting to me
about yannex point is maybe we can just
plug in at some lower level of the
kernel there
and just upload a bit of data somewhere
and now now it's able to look i'm sure
there are
biological limits to this right like
whatever it is in our mind that forms
memories
structure the linkages between neurons
or chemical potentials wherever that's
sort of an open question still but
whatever it is there may be again
physical constraints
on how fast those can form in our mind
in a way that's useful
because for example sleep there's a lot
of research that indicates sleep is very
an important process and reformatting
and reorganizing
that type of information so these are so
many open questions it'll be fascinating
it'll be a fascinating technology to
to explore if they get it working that's
for sure even that point is quite
interesting because you're implying that
there's an intermediate staging area for
information
and during sleep our brain kind of uh
you know consolidates and moves it
around
compressed defragments
we upgrade our brain to ssds we won't
have the problem
you know how i don't know if terrified
is right but he gets really depressed
when he starts talking about ai
ending the world you know it's going to
kill us all nobody's listening to me
like i've given up telling people he
just wants to get himself loaded
into an ai as quickly as possible so he
can be part of that
be part of that civilization exactly
it's quite interesting as well because
at the beginning he spoke about jeff
hawkins
inspired him because he wrote this book
and in about 2004 and it had this vision
of the mind as a multi-scale
hierarchy of temporal prediction models
and so there's conceptions of
intelligence as being a form of
prediction
as well as you know hutter's conception
of intelligence being a form of
compression
so to to add more on lots of conceptions
well that's exactly it you can you can
think about it in so many different ways
but charlay argued on the compression
point that cognition is about hedging
for the for future uncertainty
so compressing is a tool that the human
toolkit
a tool in the human tool kit used in
many ways but cognition is about being
able to operate in future situations
which contain uncertainty and novelty
yeah well there's a there is a
relationship probably there because
if you think about let's say some forms
of compression algorithms
like let's say the one used by jpeg
right where it creates
ffts or fourier faces or whatever
you know what it's looking for there to
get the compression is basis functions
if i what is it that jpeg uses dct
or something maybe discrete cosine i
don't remember the details but
the point is you choose some basis
functions for lossy compression
you're fitting a set of weights for
these different basis functions
and so in doing that in a sense they do
become
possibly more generalizable right
because you're smoothing you're
smoothing a little bit and you're
starting to ignore
some of the higher frequency information
that really trips up
like image recognition algorithms for
example with the adversarial
adversarially generated images and and
whatnot so
i think because a lot of compression
algorithms rely on using
things like basis functions you start to
achieve
some type of generalizable capability
there but i i
while compression may be helpful for
intelligence disagree with the
conception of intelligence as
compression i tend to agree much more
with
temporal hierarchies or something like
first order logic and some weird
generalized way that covers more than
just symbolic reasoning
yeah sure but even if you conceptualized
it as a
kind of temporal prediction you could
argue that compression
and prediction is pretty much the same
thing
but let's because we've got 15 minutes
let's let's move on to gpth3 because i
think this is the bit that excites us
all the most
gpt3 is this amazing language model with
175 billion parameters and
400 bucks a month it's only 400 bucks a
month it can it can produce
incredibly plausible and context-aware
information
so lex spoke about there could be gptn
there's no limit in sight this could
just go on and on
and interestingly enough though the
compute bottleneck is not the problem
the data is the bottleneck it's already
been trained on all the data in the
internet and there's lots of bias in it
and of course gpt3 already doesn't know
about coronavirus it's quite limited
in what it knows maybe they could create
a continuously fine-tuned version of g
that's what is
looking at twitter i don't know corona
what
i'm sorry you guys i'm not making sense
of what you're saying here
but it's really interesting though
because uh
it's the total opposite of people right
it's whatever
gpt3 learn from the internet it's very
different from what people learn from
life
because as soon as anyone heard about
a virus pandemic or whatever wow
like that brings forth entire structures
in our minds as to what's going on
exactly so
one of the interesting things about gbt3
which might be
incredible is this ability potentially
to learn a new task just with a few
examples
but you always get the question of is it
memorizing skills or is it actually
generally
learning something and we really don't
know because it's been trained on data
on the entire internet so you can give
it something
and it might possibly have just seen
that thing somewhere on the internet
well it raises the entire question of
what does it
mean to generalize and are humans
generalizing well because they have seen
a few instances of whatever
somewhere and or not or is it
fundamentally different i think
it's it raises a lot of it raises a lot
of questions
how we even assess again yeah coming
back to the beginning how we assess
intelligence how we assess
kind of systems like this i've been you
know arguing for a long time that it is
very
good at interpolating data and it's it
appears to have saved the training data
in some sort of
abstract distributed fashion and then
interpolates between
that which but then you can say yeah
that's what humans do
right because you have your memories and
you save them somewhere in your brain
and then you interpolate you
you have this new thing you need to do i
don't know what it is
like drive a here you go drive a
motorbike instead of a bicycle you can
transfer that skill you've
done it a couple of times and well
i feel like a lot of human intelligence
evolved around
extrapolating like even just in the sort
of think about
the physical world right it's if i'm
trying to go throw spears
at some type of animal for hunting or
whatever
i i can't interpolating the motion
within the range in which i can move
it's not really very useful what's
useful for me is in my mind being able
to extrapolate and project this
trajectory
out to some point away from me and you
can think about a lot of the things
necessary for survival
it's really more about extrapolating
and and that's sort of this generalized
you know notion of generalization which
is
let me take what i know in this little
confined domain
and apply it to something further away
at a point that
i think was made also in the interview
which is that with the ability to go
outside of the domain in which you've
learned is some
some key property in the definition of
intelligence
and does gpd3 do you think or
do they think gpt3 exhibits that you
can't throw spears it's just in the text
domain so it
might be a bit harder to assess that
sort of stuff
but can it write a novel that actually
people would enjoy reading
well you can just copy paste one
plagiarism it does do incredible things
that there have been lots of examples i
think there was a thing on hacker news
recently where it
wrote an incredibly convincing article
or website and
people believed it and it got voted and
it was generated by gbt3
and so it seems to be optimized for co
coherence is that the right word or
plausibility but
charlay said that it was really bad on
consistency and
factfulness so it's really easy to trip
it up
and lots of people are bad with
factfulness so i don't know why that
would be considered unintelligent
they certainly are but it seems to be
like a kind of
low-level thing because when we have
this
almost topological framework of
understanding and high-level reasoning
and
we can explain charlay said that in
order for us to constrain gpt3
we need to be able to explicitly program
over it
and that's so that's how our minds work
we have some kind of generative model
which will just spew the words out but
we can explicitly reason
and instruct and constrain what comes
out of our mouths
are you sure i mean
that's the entire debate is this
happening implicitly
in this language model already is so the
experiment we if you look at the
internal states of the language model
could you parse out the
kind of reasoning framework from it or
is it really something fundamentally
different than what you do
is it that you do some symbolic
operations and then you generate
language on top of that
or is it that you as you generate
language even the process is somehow
locked
with together with the production of
language
that you're reasoning i'm not sure i
don't i have no clue
it it's it's a really good question do
you do you think that
language is a layer on the top of the
operating system so do you think that
there's some process beneath it
which generates the language i think so
and you think that's something which you
could use to direct the generation of
the language
within the context of gpt three i don't
know within within the context of a
human mind yes
it's certainly an interesting
philosophical question just whether or
not neural networks could reason
yeah but then you'd have to define what
reason means and then we're back at the
beginning because
we we have some again we have some
intuition that it should involve some
sort of
logic manipulation of symbols but also
it should be not super constrained like
when people reason they don't reason by
exact principles of logic there's some
intuition behind it there's some notion
of searching of predicting the future
yeah i don't think anyone has yet has
yet exactly put the finger on what it
means to reason and therefore
we probably can't say yes or no to that
okay well on the bottleneck issue then
chalet raised an interesting point he
said he worked at google and he was
working on some image classifier and the
first version of it they
took images off random web pages and it
was so noisy on the labels i think they
actually just did a word cloud
or something so that they they were just
guessing about which words could be used
as labels for the images and they
trained on all of the images on the
internet and
the punch line was that having a much
smaller
data set with less noise is better it
converges quicker it's got better
accuracy
and is it a similar thing with gbt3 have
we now
run out of the amount of data that we
can use and are we barking up the wrong
tree by just using all of the
information on the internet well they
are already doing
a bit of this right because they're
already
sampling at different frequency from
their different repositories of data so
they have i think the google books and
wikipedia data sets they massively over
sample those because they
figure that there's probably more
information dense and also more
linguistically
correct information in there and then
whatever they get from the rest of the
internet
they they just under sample with respect
to that
yeah sorry oh sorry i didn't mean to
interrupt you like i just want to say it
and i know
tim we talked about this quite a bit but
look i
personally i believe that in a sense
neural networks are a dead end
right now like really what we need to do
is think a lot more about
topological intelligence about
say image recognition algorithms that
have built-in
affine variants which humans seem to be
able to
do and understand quite well i know a
hot dog if it's a hot dog right in front
of my face or
a hundred you know feet away i can tell
it's a i can tell it's a hot dog
and i can ignore the blades of grass and
everything else so i think this is just
a symptom of kind of a very
uh very early and limited approach to
machine learning
i.e neural networks and that at some
point once we start investing a lot more
time
in higher order systems
new forms of non-linearity logical
systems we'll we'll find out that
there's plenty of data
it wasn't data really that was the
problem it was encoding
that was the problem really
well that is i agree completely with
this
in terms though of neural networks being
at a dead end i
maybe from the architectural sense but
it seems that we still have
kind of one or two orders of magnitude
to go with just
scaling them and it sounds boring and it
sounds dumb and it's like
against the i've seen like a tweet the
other day
oh open ai has these many amazing
researchers and the best they can come
up with is to build
bigger neural networks but there is
something to this where
yes transformers are essentially the
most boring thing
right it's basically a fully connected
network on steroids
with the where the connections are also
dynamic it's everything with everything
and we just
pack layers and we just put in data and
but what comes out
is amazing and i've said for a long time
this gpt3 and
maybe even more gpt-4 once it comes out
will be
if not it will be a game changer for
many
industries in this world and openly i
knows this that's why they price it
these are alleged prices but that's why
they price it at 400 bucks a month
but this really it will be a game
changer for many industries
and yeah so i i get what you're saying
but i think what i'm making this
efficiency argument again like agreeing
that efficiency
is somehow also related to intelligence
because
okay fine we keep going down neural
networks as they are today and we scale
them and great what i'm saying is that
some decades from now when we actually
make
significant breakthroughs in more
topological methods
we're going to find out that they
absolutely dominate
sort of the just the neural networks as
they stand today
like pound for pound given the same
resources the same compute resources
yeah i can see that yeah like i made
this analogy
sorry tim i just want to bring up this
analogy i brought up a couple calls ago
which is it
if i'm going to fit a parabola and i
don't know how to do x squared
and instead i just use rectified linear
basis functions
sure i can fit the parabola with like a
whole bunch of rectified linear
functions but on the other hand the guy
that knows how to just multiply two
numbers
is going to annihilate me with just two
parameters right
yeah yeah this is exactly it i think
it's almost it's almost an unfortunate
situation on the internet we have so
much textual information
and we can build these epic language
models and they are so big now that
we're almost heading towards a phase
change
where they could potentially disrupt so
many different industries
something like a gpt3 model makes it
easier than ever to
usefully find and harness knowledge
it's more than just information
retrieval it's actually doing
stuff for you in an incredible way but
then you you talk about computer vision
applications and that's when it falls
down
because as you say we will never have
the
diversity and scale of information let's
say self-driving cars for example
we're never going to be able to brute
force that maybe we can to a certain
extent up to level four
chalet argued that it doesn't even
require real artificial general
intelligence to do self
you know driving cars but if we want to
have something which really is
at a level of sophistication i think
approaching what we can do
charlay said that we can go to japan and
we can just drive on the roads just
using all of the things that we've
learned in
in the states or london no algorithm
could do that
we need to use deep learning for what
it's good at which is perception models
but then explicitly program the control
modules probably just using
symbolic reasoning
yeah that makes sense i wasn't referring
to
by the way i wasn't referring to
intelligence as such i i just think that
this
this the technology itself it's whether
intelligent or not will be
is huge and will probably be huge if
just by mere scaling oh i see yeah so i
when i was saying it's at a dead end i i
more meant within the context of
generalizable intelligence yeah i agree
with that yeah
absolutely but yeah just to finish could
you take on keith's point about if you
have
a parabola and you try and fit it with
relo uh relu
you're going to need an incredibly high
amount of information
infinitely many yeah yeah yeah so what
does that mean
in language processing well i can just
build the example further and say okay
if i know
x to the 10th power and all the powers
below that i'm going to be terrible
again
which you get into the classical
overfitting thing
in that it's not
i see your point that if i know
something more i can
have potentially fit this data better
but also
if i know the wrong thing more i can
maybe fit it worse
so the fact that well that's exactly
what i'm saying
is that the thing you can do more is
exactly in line with the data you want
to fit
and i'm i totally agree with you
that in in the future we might
and we probably will find architectural
developments uh maybe training
developments what not
ways to pre-process the data that are
just so much better
because we have some new ability but
this needs to be carefully
researched we can't just increase number
of abilities
and and hope for that it's almost like
finding some sort of
because if i tell you here i have this
parabola here are all the mathematical
operations
that you could possibly do yeah because
so
i i think in a way if i as a human being
figure out that i needed x squared and x
cubed
at some point i'm going to figure out as
well that i just need
x to the n or actually x to the y
where y is maybe some real number that
i'm fitting and i'm going to be
intelligent about
how i assign priors to that variable
whatever jeffrey's prior
some some type of parsimonious sort of
system so the point i'm making here is
that
whatever humans are doing we're great or
well i can't say great
we're better than neural networks at
parsimony
and at finding parsimonious solutions
and i think the
and i think the community the machine
learning community has not
devoted nearly as much effort as we need
to
into developing parsimonious algorithms
and look at the end of the day we live
in an actual universe that has certain
physical laws
and whatnot and so i'm just saying we
need to encode
more of that properly more of that prior
knowledge
because we don't live in some arbitrary
arbitrarily changing
universe and the more we can encode this
type of fundamental
more generalizable sorts of knowledge
with parsimonious you know kind of
outcomes i think is my point that's what
i was
it could like so it is incredibly hard
to encode that like we have no clue how
to encode this
so could a way there to be let's build
as humanity one giant gpt thing
that is is this blank slate but takes
all the information
and then somehow that thing now contains
these priors across the world
right now it's in language on the
internet but if we could input
giant amounts of data into this one
thing that will
capture these priors and then on top of
that we could build something that makes
use
of these priors but the fundamental
dichotomy is do we
create the priors or do we learn them
well
it sounds like i'm pointing out the
obvious but the fundamental philosophy
and the deep learning world at the
moment is the blank slate
the connectionist ideology is all about
you just said the transformers
thing connects everything to everything
you can do anything and
throw loads of data at it and it will
just figure it all out
so in principle so i don't have any real
problem
with the statement that in principle you
could build some massive thing and learn
everything from scratch
like i don't have a problem with that
but the issue is that
if you go back to the days of digital
computers versus analog
computers right the earth itself and
more broadly the universe has been
performing this sort of analog
computation here on the earth for
billions of years and it ended up
producing
sort of a human mind that from the the
conglomeration of that
learning process essentially has uh
codified or encoded a lot of valuable
information and so my point is let's not
throw that out
let's really carefully survey that and
and try to
codify as much as we can and get it kind
of baked in and compiled
into our sort of basis functions as you
will for learning because otherwise
and if i think if we do that pound for
pounds cpu for cpu
will get a lot more out of our whatever
they are
neural networks or whatever you want to
call them then we will
we just say let's just start over and do
everything from scratch and principle
sure you can
but i think we'll make a lot more
progress if we at least try to survey
what's been evolved or designed or
however you want to look at it
up into this this noggin of ours so yeah
so
so this is what charlay calls core
knowledge
he thinks that we should imbue this core
knowledge into the algorithms
but what you said is quite interesting
because you said there's nothing bad in
theory about learning something from
scratch
but in a way there is because these
transformers models they don't really
learn
what they should learn computer vision
models they always
learn surface shortcuts and textures and
all sorts of things that we
clearly know are not the right thing
they should be learning it just happens
to work statistically it's just
pattern matching so surely there is an
argument for us to really think about
this and
put even better prize into these systems
well look up first of all i'm not i
can't go as far as to say
that what they're learning is
necessarily bad
i i think it's my view is if you encode
all this core knowledge
then they can learn and fit that core
knowledge i think they'll also end up
finding all kinds of little weird things
that we as people never discovered
because of kind of their i don't know we
talked the other day about the fact that
the spherical wave comes through a lens
and maybe it has some aberration
patterns here and there
that because of just efficiency reasons
the human mind has learned to ignore
but on the other hand there's obviously
information in that because scientists
learned information from looking at
things like
aberrations and and whatnot so what i
want to do is give them the power to see
all
the core knowledge and then see what
kinds of crazy stuff
they can discover on top of that that's
actually useful
because i'm sure there's useful
information there it's just i don't need
them to learn
crazy stuff that would be obsolete if
they just had core knowledge
that yes i i completely agree too it
just all depends on how well we can
specify and encode that core knowledge
because if if we misspecify it
it already maybe blocks a path to some
of these
informations by that do you mean it's
substrate specific
so well if you say for example the sky
is always up
right that's a core knowledge like i'm
like this is not but if we think of it
like this is
generally true but then if you're at the
on the iss or what not that's not true
or if you're in australia
the sky is down and then you
you forbid the ai from going down
that alley because it's just going to
operate under that assumption that the
sky is always up
so i agree with you you have to be
careful about it i would probably code
it more as
in some direction there is a sky or the
sky is in some direction and just give
it the knowledge of directionality
of sort of a 3d vector that points
somewhere and that there's a
spherical hull or whatever in some
direction there
so we do have to be careful you don't
want core now
you want core knowledge to be general
i hate to say that word general but yes
don't make core knowledge so specific
that it becomes a constraint it's more
about
coding in structure if you will like the
group structure
or other kinds of structure but but the
point i was making though is
to take one of charlay's examples
objectiveness
it's still the way you code it depends
on the substrate of the information so
if you have a computer vision
application which
there's a camera it's at some point it
corresponds to
pixels that it might be a numpy array or
something that
that has free color channels and the way
that you implement that prior
is in the substrate of how the
information comes to you and that seems
to bias it straight away
well so my take on that is that
whenever we encode whenever we encode
a core knowledge if you will we should
take care to encode its opposite as well
and allow it to be parameterized so if
i'm going to encode objectness
i would also encode the concept of
diffuseness
because look sometimes the boundaries
between objects
are hard to define like i have a bucket
of ice cream here
now what happens if i scoop out a piece
you know at what point does it become
an object in and of itself and this
like what we're discussing right now i
think is itself a part of the core
knowledge
of the world is the fact that that there
are structures there are duals of
structures
there are anti-structures that's part of
our core knowledge that we discovered
over time
okay yeah i agree i agree with that and
this
this goes into many ideas that are
around
in like banjo has this notion of the
consciousness priors which is this kind
of factor graph
where he says there are explanatory
variables that are sparsely connected
and so on i think
lots of people trying to to abstract
that i
think it's hard like you said it's
extremely first it's extremely hard and
second of all it's
it for the ones that are com probably
come closer to reality they're not
really computationally
yet visible i hear you there i i felt
like when i was in graduate school
trying to do research
at some point i had some simple physical
model
what i thought was a very simple model
right and i needed to
integrate it i couldn't figure out how
to integrate it
mathematica couldn't figure out how to
integrate it so i went to the library
and i got we had these
sort of back in whenever it was the 40s
through 70s or something
the russians produced these massive
tomes of all kinds of
series and integrations and things like
that so i go look up
my equation and it was actually a series
and i found it in there great and it had
a name
so this is the sterling series of the
second kind i'm like oh cool it's got a
name and it says turn to page
1326 so i go get that volume
i look it up and it says the sterling
series of the second kind is defined by
this equation
and that's it like on to the next
session and i'm like a section i'm like
okay
if the russians couldn't figure out
anything i can't figure out
anything with this series and at that
moment i realized for my whole life
all the math problems i've been giving
had all these convenient
solutions you could go look up in the
back of the book and check your answer
make sure it's correct
but as you're saying reality the
physical world
throws at you these simple things that
just aren't computationally
you know feasible or have no symbolic
solution it's like you look at the
equations for gr
they're they're not high school
equations but they're not really that
complex yet finding solutions for them
pretty hard agree well
just to finish off then uh lex asked
chalet what he thought the meaning of
life was
i'm interested to get your take on this
he says that even your
most personal thoughts are not yours
everything we do creates ripples and
these ripples are the meaning of life
uh we are cultural beings that's what
makes us different from animals
everything about us is an echo of the
past if we create anything it becomes
part of the minds of future humans
so as we contribute to culture ourselves
it creates ripples going forwards
and that's a very kind of philosophical
thing for him to say but he does believe
that
um culture is externalized intelligence
and he has a very
collective conception of our place on on
this planet
not to wax too too poetic but i agree
with that sentiment i mean me
and this kind of gets back to our first
discussion to me the meaning of life is
love
and the sense that i genuinely care
about
what's happening to other people and
that we as a species
progress like in a positive way and i
want us to be around
somewhere in the universe for as long as
possible that's my opt
you know what i'm trying to optimize
there i get it eventually
protons are going to decay and nothing
will be left but
if we look back and say if we integrated
the number of human beings
over the course of time i want that
number to be as large as possible if you
will
and so even going to things like the
testing scandal
my motivation there is i want as many
people as possible to achieve
as much as possible and so how do we get
there that's my question
yeah i got nothing to add
yeah it's a big it's a big question and
it's a nice answer
and i agree with it interesting
and of course the if you look at what
makes up your
bodies it existed before you were both
born
and will continue to exist after we die
yeah and lots of it came from the
apparently the collision of neutron
stars now that's the
prevailing theory for a lot of heavy
metal generations
exactly we are made of stars well uh
this has been an incredible conversation
thank you so much and
we will be back next week talking about
a computer vision paper we've spoken a
lot about
contrastive unsupervised vision
algorithms but we're going to do it
again
next friday so tune in for that and cfx
thank you cheers